so if the new battlefront doesn't
scratch your Star Wars edge Sony may
have some good news for you the
publisher revealed that the Super
Nintendo classic super Star Wars is also
making its way to PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation Vita this week the action
platformer was first released on
Nintendo's console in 1992 and then
re-released for the Wii Virtual Console
in 2009 the PlayStation release
according to Sony is an enhanced version
that has new save features leaderboards
trophies and updated display and
controller options super star wars is
also listed as a cross by title which
means that buying it on ps4 or Vita will
also unlock it on the other dices Star
Wars Battlefront meanwhile launches on
November 17 for Xbox one ps4 and PC EA
has also released a new live-action
trailer for the game featuring Twilight
and pitch perfect actor Anna Kendrick
Star Wars Battlefront trophies and
achievements have also been revealed and
EA has launched the free battlefront
companion app which features a card game
and more so what do you think do you
plan on taking a trip down memory lane
or will you stick with Battlefront this
week personally I'm just gonna watch
force awakens trailers over and over
again until I get my fix